und für den neuen
Bundesverteidigungsminister der uns aus
Berlin zugeschaltet ist guten Abend Herr
Pistorius guten Abend Frau Slomka ja was
ein Tag kaum ernannt mit der Urkunde in
der Hand dann das Treffen mit dem
mächtigsten Amtskollegen Austin wie ist
das Gespräch denn verlaufen haben Sie
den Eindruck da bahnt sich jetzt eine
Entscheidung an Stichwort Kampfpanzer
das könnte sein in der Tat das Gespräch
war war sehr offen und erfreulich wir
haben uns sehr gut verstanden auf
annehmen und wir haben uns vorgenommen
uns regelmäßig auszutauschen ich glaube
das ist auch wichtig in diesen Zeiten
einen engen Draht zu pflegen
Entscheidungen sind heute nicht gefallen
die werden an anderer Stelle getroffen
aber wir haben über alle Fragen der
transatlantischen Zusammenarbeit
gesprochen und das war wichtig und
notwendig nicht nur in Bezug auf die
Ukraine sie sagten gerade das könnte
sein also wurde auch über abrames und
Leopard 2 oder 1 gesprochen
wir haben überall diese Fragen im
vertraulichen Gespräch natürlich
gesprochen
aber im Wesentlichen im Rahmen eines
Austausches und eine Austausch der
Position die Gespräche laufen auf andere
Ebene 40 morgen vielleicht bis morgen
herausstellen welche Lösung es gibt aber
ich bleibe dabei wenn ich das sagen darf
wir haben sind sehr gut gefahren als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und als
Bündnispartner in den letzten 12 Monaten
dass die großen wichtigen Entscheidungen
zur Unterstützung der Ukraine immer im
transatlantischen Schulterschluss
getroffen worden sind und ich sehe
ehrlich gesagt keinen Grund warum man
davon ausgerechnet jetzt wenn es um
einen der größten und hochgerissenen
panzerkampfpanzer wie den Leopard 2 geht
anders sein sollte deswegen ist hier ein
konzertiertes Vorgehen ganz ganz wichtig
aber eine Einheit innerhalb der Europäer
wäre doch auch wichtig jetzt sieht so
aus die Briten liefern Kampfpanzer die
Fragen erst gar nicht mehr die Polen und
die finden sagen wir wollen unsere
Leoparden liefern die Deutschen müssen
jetzt bitte ja sagen und gibt's heute
auch noch diese Tallinn Initiative und
ich Großbritannien in Island die beiden
empfohlen und die Niederländer an die
Spitze gesetzt haben und Deutschland
steht irgendwie daneben
den Eindruck habe ich nicht der Eindruck
wird erweckt in der Tat aber tatsächlich
ist es so dass Deutschland zusammen mit
Großbritannien nach den USA der größte
Unterstützer der Ukraine in diesem
furchtbaren Krieg ist und in dieser
Rolle sehen wir uns tatsächlich auch für
die Zukunft aber das heißt nicht dass
man jede Entscheidung auch im Alleingang
treffen muss Bündnis Verpflichtung heißt
eben auch dass ein Bündnis
zusammenstehen muss und Entscheidungen
gemeinsam treffen muss und gemeinsame
Leistungen erbringen muss und um solche
Fragen muss es dann eben auch gehen und
wenn das dann ein paar Tage dauert dann
ist das so aber von alleine dann kann
doch gar keine Rede mehr sein der
Alleingang besteht doch jetzt eher darin
dass die Deutschen blockieren was andere
liefern wollen ja wir blockieren
zunächst mal nicht wir sagen man kann
über alles reden aber wir wollen den
transatlantischen Schulterschluss das
ist keine Blockade das ist der Weg zu
einem gemeinsamen Ziel das heißt da
geht's vor allen Dingen um die USA warum
ist es dem Kanzler warum ist es dann
jetzt künftig auch Ihnen als
Verteidigungsminister so wichtig dass
die Amerikaner da auch Kampfpanzer
liefern dass die mit im Boot sitzen weil
sie die Sorge haben dass ich Russland
sonst vielleicht allein an Deutschland
rechnen würde
was heißt allein an Deutschland es gibt
um die Europäische Union es geht um
Mitteleuropa Großbritannien und
Frankreich sind atomare Mächte
Deutschland nicht es geht schlicht darum
dass wir die Sicherheit in der Balance
halten sowohl der Kanzler als auch ich
heute haben ein Eid geschworen Schaden
vom deutschen Volk abzuwenden das ist
unser Auftrag gleichzeitig haben wir
eine Bündnis Verpflichtung und beides in
Einklang zu bringen das ist unsere
Pflicht und das tun wir mit voller
Überzeugung aber wenn sie gerade darauf
hinweisen dass Deutschland keine Atom
macht ist heißt dass der Kanzler
vertraut nicht auf die NATO Strukturen
sondern er will dass die Amerikaner auf
jeden Fall auch Abrams liefern obwohl
die das eigentlich gar nicht wollen und
sagen zu können hallo Leute wir machen
das alle gemeinsam oder nein das habe
ich wieder gesagt noch gemeint um Gottes
Willen der weder der Kanzlerin auch ich
stellen die Bündnis Verpflichtungen die
Einhaltung der Bündnis Verpflichtung und
die Bündnis treuen Fall diskutiert wird
aufgrund dieses Jungtier ja das kann
sein aber da muss ich dann denjenigen
die das tun auch umgekehrt unterstellen
dass das vielleicht nicht ganz rein
gewisses passiert in jeder weiß dass das
nicht der Fall ist
die entscheidende Frage ist doch machen
wir so was alleine als Europäer als ein
Teil von Europa womöglich nur oder
machen wir es im Schulterschluss mit den
Amerikanern was immer das bedeutet dann
im Schulterschluss aber die Amerikaner
außen vorzulassen als den größten
Bündnispartner hielte ich in dieser
Frage eben auch für falsch aber was
heißt denn außen vor die Amerikaner
liefern jede Menge eventuell werden Sie
heute Abend oder morgen verkünden dass
sie auch an ein neues Waffensystem an
die Ukraine liefern präzisionsbomben mit
150 km Reichweite das wäre ein echter
gamechanger und zwar mindestens so
wichtig wie die Kampfpanzer also es ist
ja nicht so als müsste man die
Amerikaner jetzt noch über diese Abrams
unbedingt ins Boot holen das muss doch
nicht jeder das selber liefern sondern
die die am besten was liefern können
liefern oder ja das stimmt aber wir
reden wir reden über einen kampfmann
sowie den Leopard 2 der eine der besten
und auch offensivtauglichsten ist den es
gibt und demzufolge ist es eben mit
Vorsicht zu genießen ihn jetzt einfach
so rauszugeben wir sind uns darüber im
Klaren dass er eine wichtige Rolle
spielen kann aber eben nicht nur er und
ich wiederhole mich die das atlantische
Vereinbarung die transatlantische
Zusammenarbeit hat einen eigenen
Stellenwert ich bin ziemlich sicher es
wird sehr bald zu einer Lösung kommen
sie sagten die Ukraine also noch jetzt
bevor Sie dieses Amt angetreten sind die
Ukraine muss gewinnen das muss man ja
dann auch definieren für die Ukraine
bedeutet gewinnen nicht dass die Dinge
jetzt so bleiben wie sie sind sondern
sie wollen ihr Territorium zurückerobern
und sehen wir bei allem was jetzt schon
geliefert wurde gerade im Osten gerade
dabei bachmut das sind grauenhaft
abnutzungs- und stellungskriege und um
diese zu durchbrechen bräuchte es ja das
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen also auch
mit Kampfpanzern die gehören damit dazu
sagen Militärs kann es sein dass die
deutsche Bundesregierung das bislang gar
nicht will eben weil sie fürchtet dass
Putin dann was immer auch macht wenn er
dann so ins Hintertreffen käme ich kann
das definitiv von nein das ist nicht die
Sorge der Bundesregierung uns geht es
darum ich kann das nur wiederholen dass
wir die Ukraine unterstützen wo immer
wir können niemand schließt aus das
Leopard Panzer geliefert werden können
oder dass die Genehmigung die Zustimmung
zu der Lieferung andere europäischer
Partner erteilt werden kann aber der bis
dahin sind noch nicht alle Fragen
beantwortet und das passiert gegenwärtig
ist aber interessant dass sie sagen
niemand schließt aus bisher war das
schon ziemlich ausgeschlossen das ist
mein Bild nicht es ist nur gesagt zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht es ist keine
dauerhafte nach meinem Kenntnisstand
keine dauerhaft kein dauerhafter
Ausschluss einer solchen Möglichkeit
erfolgt ist mein Kenntnisstand
jedenfalls nicht wie bewerten sie denn
dass die Polen sagen also wenn die
Deutschen sich nicht bewegen sinngemäß
dann liefern wir halt was wir wollen
dann machen wir das auch ohne Zustimmung
das wäre eine Entscheidung der
polnischen Regierung die ich dann
kommentieren würde wenn sie eintrete
tatsache ist aber es gibt bis heute
keinen Antrag weil meines Wissens
jedenfalls auferteilung einer solchen
Exportgenehmigung ist mein Stand von
heute morgen ist natürlich ein bisschen
formalistisch gesagt haben sie es
öffentlicher nun immer wieder und
ausdrücklich
ja gut aber wie gesagt wenn die Polen
sagen sie machen es ohne Genehmigung
dann wird man das Kommentieren wenn es
passiert hielt das nicht für besonders
Bündnis freundlich aber das sind dann
halt Dinge die passieren dafür sie leben
wir in Zeiten in denen es eben wirklich
unruhig ist und der ein oder andere dann
eben auch seine Rolle anders definiert
da bist Du was ich fast noch mal
zusammen wir können damit rechnen dass
morgen in Ramstein doch entscheidendes
verkündet wird kann ich das so mitnehmen
und unsere Zuschauer ich hoffe darauf
dann danke ich Ihnen für das Gespräch
sehr gerne